deux ans presque jour pour jour après
l'accident mortel de la princesse diana
le parquet de paris vient de requérir un
non-lieu général et le ministère public
demande donc l'abandon des poursuites à
l'encontre des neuf photographes et du
motard de presse mise en examen mais
c'est au juge d'instruction maintenant
que revient la décision de poursuivre ou
non
valérie ermite fanny auvergne deux ans
d'une phénoménale enquête sur un
tragique et médiatique accident peu
après minuit ce 31 août 97 diana dodi al
fayed et leur chauffeur henri paul
trouvent la mort dans le tunnel de
l'alma premiers coupables désignés les
photographes ils suivent le couple
depuis la matinée et ce serait pour
l'heure échapper que la princesse serait
morte
ce n'est que plus tard que le taux
d'alcoolémie du chauffeur de la mercedes
sera connu
henri paul avait bu et pris des
médicaments
de plus henri pâle roulait beaucoup trop
vite et sa mercedes a heurté une fiat
uno encore introuvable à ce jour pour le
parquet de paris baillet mains de dial
fayed et henri-paul sont donc mort d'un
accident de la circulation et les
photographes n'ont pas à être poursuivi
le parquet s'est rendu compte qu'il n'y
avait aucun élément juridique qui
permettait de poursuivre les
photographes
encore une fois on peut porter le
jugement moral que l'on veut sur le
comportement qu'ils ont pu avoir mais
sur un flop sur un plan juridique il n'y
a aucun comportement pénalement
répréhensible seul survivant de
l'accident
travel rhys-jones le garde du corps
tenait plutôt pour responsable la
direction de l'hôtel ritz pour avoir
confié la voiture à un non professionnel
et n'en voulait en aucun cas aux
photographes
personnellement elle s'est aussi
avidement clients j'ai toujours eu le
sentiment que les photographes n'était
pas responsable de cet accident qui est
dû à chauffard ivre qui n'avaient pas la
licence appropriée et à l'hôtel ritz qui
a exigé que ce chauffeur conduisent par
conséquent je ne peux me réjouir pour
les photographes
même si je ne les défends pas qu' il ne
soit plus poursuivis par le parquet
injoignable pour l'instant le père de
dodi mohamed al fayed sera
vraisemblablement l'un des seuls à
contester ces réquisitions
un non lieu qui n'est cependant pas
définitif les juges d'instruction de
vidal et stefan vont maintenant décider
seul si les photographes doivent être
poursuivis ou non